the town of chaman in the province of
balochistan has been a major point of
entry for afghans into pakistan but
besides refugees it has also been used
in the past by afghan taliban members to
enter pakistan correspondent shazeeb
jillani traveled to the town of quetta
not too far from chaman to bring us this
report on how pakistan has provided safe
harbor for the militant group
the garrison city of quetta in
balochistan western citizens are not
allowed here unless they have permission
from the central government in islamabad
this bustling street is known as kantari
bazaar named after the influential city
in afghanistan
the two cities have historical trade and
cultural ties ethnic push stones move
seamlessly between the two cities
they share a common pashto language and
a conservative version of islam
the city has seen a lot of violence
police and soldiers stand guard at
mosques to prevent further attacks
[Music]
okay so we've just been to the friday
prayers in quetta located on kandhari
bazaar road the mosque was jam-packed as
expected the cleric who gave the friday
sermon
celebrated
america's defeat in afghanistan and he
also called people to be generous and
give donations for helping taliban in
afghanistan
a short drive north of quetta afghan
taliban flags have gone up over shops
and homes
we saw graveyards of taliban soldiers
who died fighting nato troops in
afghanistan
for much of the last two decades
pakistan denied sheltering the afghan
militants but now it is open and widely
accepted
in 2019 it helped pave the way for the
taliban to be brought to the negotiating
table with the u.s
last month that allowed the return of
the taliban in kabul
but opposition politicians warned that
pakistan will have to pay a price for
its involvement in afghanistan is kaju
backlash
we are worried about the backlash which
could be disastrous
if the taliban failed to establish peace
there will be refugee influx cross body
smuggling of drugs and weapons
experts like rafiola kakar also fear
that the chaos next door could boost
extremism and erode democratic rights in
pakistan my primary concern is that the
taliban controlled afghanistan will
embolden islamic militancy in pakistan
and within pakistan the areas that are
located along pakistan's border with
afghanistan will bear the brunt of this
blowback of taliban's
ascendancy in afghanistan
pakistani officials said they had to
nurture and maintain deep ties with the
afghan taliban because it served the
country's national interest the country
paid a huge price in terms of suicide
bombings mass violence and a shattered
economy many people in quetta and
balochistan are now worried that with
the return of taliban in afghanistan the
country should prepare itself for tough
times ahead
let's get some perspective on this from
bushra gohar a former member of
pakistan's parliament welcome mrs gohar
shazeeb was saying in his report from
quetta that pakistani officials nurtured
ties with the taliban to serve the
national interest what is this national
interest
well this hasn't been really defined or
discussed
in pakistan's parliament and how can um
investment in terrorism be of national
interest so as far as we were concerned
when we were in parliament we questioned
the suicidal policy
and we had actually also passed a
unanimous resolution sake that
pakistan's soil should not be used
for sanctuaries for the taliban now
pakistan has been using
or
pakistan has been investing in
this policy the strategic depth policy
and has provided sanctuaries
to
[Music]
terrorists and used it as a foreign
policy
and security leverage
we have always
said that this was suicidal and it was
affecting pakistan more and that all
these sanctuaries and safe havens should
be cleared but this is an investment uh
past 20 years and even before
pakistan's
establishments links with these
terrorist groups and to call them good
and bad taliban that is also a very um
you know it's
it's a policy that uh has brought a lot
of harm to pakistan right we want to
talk about that and
you talked about the policy in terms of
a suicidal policy and also the policy of
strategic depth i'd like to pick them up
one at a time what exactly does pakistan
mean by strategic depth
well
you see pakistan has been working on
having a
strategic depth in afghanistan as far as
the region is concerned and
uh used it as
uh you know
to counter india's
uh interests also and the
since 47 the uh
the
the friction that the two countries have
now i think that this uh policy hasn't
worked and it has actually brought a lot
of uh
trouble
for the region and for pakistan and
especially for the bush students in the
tribal
areas
right and that brings me to the word
suicidal why would you say this policy
has been suicidal for pakistan
well look what where we are right now
i mean our homes have been
destroyed uh
the threats
to country the existential
threats to the country so it is suicidal
it has brought more harm to the country
rather than and it is also i mean for
the whole region it's a
policy that has
really not benefited the country how can
investing in terrorists really benefit
a country
so personally i feel that
we need to
address the problems in the region
with our neighbors without really
working through proxies
and these proxies are really i mean
there's no good bad taliban
in my opinion and
we
and
this policy because i i mean the entire
both
has been affected i was recently in
quetta and i found a
taliban
freely moving around
in the
prop
in the city this is something that we
need to question i mean
terrorists
can move around freely whereas
uh citizens who are questioning these
policies are under great threat
if i can just ask you we have about a
minute left what do you think pakistan's
policy will be now given that the
taliban are running afghanistan
well in my opinion
taliban in afghanistan and
taliban are terrorists and they are
occupying afghanistan with the support
of
certain countries and the u.s the
doha deal
gave these
terrorists legitimacy and i feel that
it's going to affect us it's going to
hit us hard
right now uh the the strategic depth
that pakistan has been working for
they might have
gotten it for
a little while but it's going to hit us
back
we'll leave it there for the time being
but thank you so much for joining us
today bushra gohar former member of
pakistan's parliament thank you so much
ma'am
let's bring in dws amrita chima our
what's the view there in india of the
recent developments in afghanistan
well
certainly none of the euphoria that you
saw in parts of pakistan pointed the
contrary there was huge alarm because
the indian government had very good
relations with successive afghan
governments over the past 20 years and
it also invested a huge amount in
afghanistan in building infrastructure
and also a hugely symbolic gesture
building the new parliament in the
country and now the taliban have
announced their cabinet and 17 out of
the 33 people in the cabinet are
people who are designated as terrorists
by the u.n and many of them are linked
to groups that india feels uh were
responsible for targeting indian indian
facilities for example the consulates in
afghanistan which were bombed by these
some of these groups so india is not at
all happy about the situation there and
it's also very worried that the interior
minister for example is linked to a
deadly group operating in pakistan the
so-called haqqani group so they are
valid at multiple levels
so what are india's other concerns then
apart from the fact that the people of
pakistan they are worried about that all
the gains made in the past 20 years for
minority rights women's rights and
democratic institutions will be rolled
back they are worried about security
because you have multiple factions
operating in afghanistan at the moment
and this is fertile ground for terrorist
organizations like the al-qaeda like the
islamic state to flourish and this will
have a destabilizing influence not just
in afghanistan but neighboring countries
like pakistan the neighbors of
afghanistan and central asia and india
is particularly worried that there will
be a spill over into its northern
territory of kashmir where it's been
fighting a separatist monitors movement
for decades
i mean as a
substantial regional power what are
india's options there
you know fairly limited to be honest at
the moment gerhard because at the moment
pakistan seems to be calling all the
shots in afghanistan and in fact some
people here feel that it's a proxy
pakistani government that you have uh in
afghanistan but india is weighing its
options it has lost a lot of diplomatic
leverage but it's working with
international organizations they've been
several high-level
visits in india from for example
intelligence chiefs from the us and
russia
and india is still very keen that
humanitarian aid should go into
afghanistan even if they do not
recognize the taliban so prime minister
modi is going to the united states next
week he'll be having a bilateral chat
with president joe biden there and
afghanistan and how to deal with
afghanistan will definitely be top of
the agenda
dws amrita there in delhi thank you amir